le lindane un insecticide toxique encore
présent aujourd'hui dans les sols et
dans l'air plus de vingt ans après son
interdiction en france il ya trop de lin
dan dans l'air trop de poussière de cet
insecticide aujourd'hui interdite avant
d'être interdit le lindane étaient
majoritairement utilisés dans
l'agriculture mais aussi dans certains
produits anti-poux et ménager la société
rhône poulenc qui fabrique l insecticide
le garantit ces mêmes biodégradables ce
pas un produit polluant mais c'est un
produit actif c'est-à-dire que il
intervient dans la biologie est il là
pour supprimer
de l'avis des insectes pourtant à cette
époque la toxicité du lin dan est déjà
pointé du doigt le point de départ se
fait divers à colmar en alsace en 1983
ici sous mes pieds
il ya 500 tonnes de la donne c'est à
dire des pesticides qui de sont là
depuis 17 ans une pollution causée par
des déchets industriels contenant du
lindane déversés dans cette carrière en
1966 agriculteurs et consommateurs
dénonçaient alors une contamination des
terres et des nappes phréatiques
la conséquence toute cette eau polluée
va se retrouver dans la région de colmar
et d'une eau et du nord de colmar et il
ya un risque d'intoxication de milliers
de personnes des craintes confirmées par
ce scientifique
c'est un toxiques du système nerveux
central et il y a des gens qui se sont
suicidés quand fêté ses sept suicides
qui ont présenté des convulsions un coma
une cyanose six ans plus tard en 1989
un autre incident relance le débat sur
la toxicité de l'insecticide le naufrage
dans la manche d'un cargo transportant
un conteneur de lin dan un risque grave
pour l'environnement selon cet
écologiste
ce produit chimique se répand dans la
manche les fesses quand une destruction
de la vie marine dans la région il
s'accumulera dans la chaîne alimentaire
dont les produits de la pêche et nous
aurons un désastre pour l'environnement
comme jamais auparavant
à cette époque le lin dan est déjà
classée comme modérément dangereux par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
mais le gouvernement français devait
aller encore plus loin selon cet élu
verts ont ce produit dangereux et
complètement interdits en allemagne
complètement interdit aux états unis en
france on en trouve encore dans un
certain nombre de produits ménagers
je crois qu'il faut l'interdire
complètement parce que même à la
respiration c'est quelque chose de très
très dangereux donc il faut agir aussi
là dessus
une mesure prise neuf ans plus tard en
le ministre de l'agriculture interdit
alors usage du lindane dans les
exploitations agricoles
mais 22 ans plus tard l'insecticide
ultra résistant est encore régulièrement
retrouvée dans les analyses de qualité
de l'air de 2013 à 2017 par exemple il a
été détecté dans plus de 35
100 des prélèvements
[Musique]